a henderson neighborhood near horizon
ridge parkway in gibson has been hit
with mailbox break-ins homeowners
telling us they are frustrated now they
have to go all the way to the post
office to pick up their mail sally
jaramillo is joining us now live with
this ongoing battle and sally how long
have they been dealing with this kind of
delay
neighbors here tell me it's become an
inconvenience no mail delivery for more
than two months they are also surprised
it happened in their gated community a
place they thought they were safe
john overall lives in this henderson
neighborhood he tells me in the past
this problem would have been fixed right
away but for some reason it is taking
months a sign on the mailboxes reads out
of service please pick up your mail at
postal service he along with his
neighbors have to drive to the post
office while it is about five minutes
away they must stand in a long line ask
for mail then wait for them to locate
their mail more of my concern is the
elderly that live in the neighborhood
who don't online bank they rely on the
mail
to pay their bills just to get through
life overall adds when he went to the
post office on horizon ridge parkway
near stephanie street workers told him
his neighborhood is not the only one
having problems as thieves are targeting
neighborhoods trying to steal tax return
checks
back out live i reached out to the
postal service for a statement and in a
statement they say
we're in the process of upgrading the
security at the cluster box unit for
enhanced protection we expect the
process to be completed within the next
seven to ten days for now reporting live
in henderson sally jaramillo live local
now